- We've seen tons of lawsuits being filed
with headline-grabbing
numbers being filed for say,
billions of dollars.
The billion dollar lawsuit from Dominion,
or billions of dollars being sought
from Facebook and Google.
But here's a secret
that only lawyers know,
that number is largely BS.
The thing is, the plaintiff can put
whatever allegations they
want into the complaint
and the number that they
seek at the very end
of the complaints, the prayer for relief
is going to have a large number.
Often, if you're launching
a lawsuit that has as much
of a PR component as it
does an actual legal basis,
then you're gonna want
to grab some headlines.
And a lot of these
lawsuits have done that.
That doesn't mean that they're entitled
to that amount of money, doesn't mean that
they're going to be awarded
that amount of money
from the judge or the jury.
It just means that a plaintiff's lawyer
wants to cover their bases
and they want to make sure
that they're not hamstrung
by seeking a small amount up front,
so they will put basically
any number that they want
at the end of the complaint.
So just remember that next
time you see a lawsuit
that is seeking billions of
dollars from someone else,
that number is largely made up.